one of the main reasons we're doing the
PPP's in Puerto Rico is because the
investment in infrastructure was very
low and he had been declining for many
years to the point that it affected
actually economic development and it's
important we incorporate private sector
private investment into infrastructure
that's why we are pursuing ppps we have
identified a large number of benefits
with the PPP's it just brings project
into reality faster than having more
traditional approaches to the projects
the other one is obviously we don't do
public debt there's no need to go to the
bond market it is all the risk of the
private sector so we're not even
committing to additional public that
there is a large difference between or
the approach that we take in three PPP's
compared to a traditional way of doing
it on the traditional way for doing it
the government will actually do all
these steps all full design construction
would not start until design is
completed until one hundred percent and
it will do the maintenance here we have
done the design and build and
maintenance transfer that to the private
sector we also did a total project which
is a very interesting one we have
managed a procurement that has
transferred to the private sector the
risk of doing capital investments
maintaining the road and doing the
operation in a very efficient manner for
drivers landscaping fixing the lighting
and restoring signage replacing signage
all the way to bridge repairs and
repayment of the toll roads and that was
new investment that wasn't available in
the government before also we have been
responsible for doing a procurement of
the airport again we're looking for
providing delivering positive change in
which up an investor will not only do
the capital improvements but also do the
maintenance and the operations of the
airport with the intention of having a
better
or better global connectivity work class
facilities this schools for the 21st
century sub is a way to restore
investment in public schools that have
been decorated for many years Barry
White's prep program across the aisle
and 100 100 schools and working in a way
that is facilitating investment in
schools at the end of the day we are
benefiting from savings the government
is not dedicating more resources to it
and taxpayers are receiving value or
because they have a better
infrastructure and better public service
and we actually achieving substantial
savings with that
I